c'est une déclaration d'amour qui a du
mal à passer auprès d'une grande partie
de la profession
dans sa lettre adressée à l'attention
des journalistes français et publié dans
le journal du dimanche l'ancien ministre
de l'intérieur et ce en pleine polémique
autour de l'article 24 de la loi
sécurité globale martèle que cette loi
ne contreviendrait pas aux droits de la
presse
nous venons de vivre une semaine pleine
de malentendus d'incompréhension de
craintes parfois une semaine qui nous
pousse à vous écrire pour une
déclaration d'amour peu usuelle cette
lettre fait suite à la mobilisation de
la profession dans plusieurs villes de
france dont paris contre la loi dit
sécurité globale et plus
particulièrement son article 24 adopté
cette semaine en première lecture
l'ancien locataire de la place beauvau
accompagné de deux co rapporteur de la
proposition de loi alice toro et
jean-michel fauvergue tous deux lrm
essaie tant bien que mal de convaincre
nous avons parfois eu des différends
c'est vrai mais il est hors de question
pour nous comme pour quiconque de
s'immiscer dans vos salles de rédaction
dans vos reportages ou sur vos réseaux
sociaux
tout comme il n'est pas question de vous
demander de vous accréditez pour pouvoir
couvrir une manifestation votre liberté
de ton c'est notre liberté démocratique
l'ex ministre va même jusqu'à tenter de
nous convaincre que cette proposition de
loi n'a rien à voir avec ce qui lui est
reproché
pour christophe castaner l'erreur a été
de se focaliser sur l'article 24 qui
semble avoir mal été interprétée par de
nombreux journalistes
le sens de cet article n'a jamais changé
mieux protéger les forces de l'ordre
sans jamais porter atteinte à la liberté
d'informer mais s'il est une chose dont
nous sommes convaincus c'est qu'aucun
article de loi ne devrait provoquer des
inquiétudes quant à de liberté sa
tribune a du mal à passer auprès de
nombreux confrères qui n'ont pas hésité
à lui rappeler ses relations avec la
presse quand il était ministre de
l'intérieur
christophe castaner aime tellement la
presse qu il a spécifiquement utiliser
la loi sécurité globale pour s'en
prendre à mediapart et propager
défectueuse peu s'en souviennent
d'autres n'hésitent pas à ironiser
rappelant aux chefs de file des députés
les rhumes à l'assemblée nationale le
bilan des violences policières
et de la maltraitance envers certains
journalistes notamment lors des
manifestations des gilet jaune
nous aussi on vous aime l'oeil dans les
yeux même ton désabusé pour catherine
gasté grand reporter au parisien qui
assure à christophe castaner les
journalistes ne sont pas en mal d'amour
ou encore pour la journaliste de
mediapart camille polloni nous ne sommes
pas en mal d'amour
il est totalement déplacée de s'adresser
aux journalistes sur un registre
affectif
chacun son métier et la liberté de la
presse sera bien gardée cher christophe
castaner merci d'arrêter de nous écrire
comme le disait hier jean-michel
fauvergue
il n'y a pas d'amour il n'ya que des
preuves d'amour bien cordialement
quoi qu'il en soit cette lettre qui se
voulait une main tendue vers la
profession semble avoir déclenché l'ire
des journalistes peut-être une façon de
rappeler l ancien ministre
le bilan de son passage place beauvau